un peu plus de deux ans après les
dernières élections municipales
élections Québec remarque une tendance à
la hausse des démissions au sein des
conseils municipaux de la province c'est
ce qu'on doit s'en inquiéter on en
discute à l'instant avec Daniel côté il
est le président de l'Union des
municipalités du Québec maire de Gaspé
bonjour
on parle de 311 élus qui aurait quitté
leur poste depuis novembre 2021
est-ce que ça vous surprend ces données
là d'élection Québec
c'est surprenant oui et non en fait ces
dernières années on a vu une
recrudescence ou une hausse
d'intimidation à l'égard des élus
municipaux surtout via les plateformes
web les élus sont très présents sur les
médias sociaux Facebook Twitter Linkin
etc et il y a quand même des gens qui
s'attaquent aux élus via les médias
sociaux ça crée une pression
supplémentaire ça favorise de nouvelles
démissions et aussi le fait qu'on sort
en fait ça fait un an et quelques qu'on
a eu les dernières élections municipales
donc peut-être des nouveaux joueurs qui
s'attendaient pas autant de travail
parce qu'on élume municipal honnêtement
c'est on est extrêmement sollicité en
extrême d'obligation à rencontrer ou
d'autres fois il y a des gens qui se
présentent en disant moi je veux tout
changer dans le temps de le dire dans la
réalité des choses les municipalités
sont très encadrées donc souvent je
risque constaté ce qu'il y avait des
déçus par des gens des déçu par rapport
à la quantité de pouvoir qui pouvait
avoir entre leurs mains donc c'est un
mélange tout ça mais on dit que c'est ce
sont surtout les petite municipalité qui
serait touchée moins de 5000 habitants
c'est pas possible effectivement
en fait dans les plus petites
municipales municipalités souvent une
question aussi de rétribution pour le
salaire pour le travail qu'on fait comme
élu municipal c'est certain que si on
paye quelqu'un dix mille dollars par
année pour une job à temps plein ça peut
arriver que la personne se décourage
après un an ou deux voyants l'ampleur de
la tâche donc peut-être ça aussi qui
vient jouer dans la balance pour les
plus petites municipalités qui ont
souvent aussi moins de personnels autour
d'eux pour les encadrer donc les élus
encore plus d'ouvrages à faire pour
atteindre leurs objectifs bref c'est
peut-être pour ça mais on n'a pas de
données scientifique à cet effet-là
c'est une analyse que je fais comme ça
vous êtes quand même mère vous-même
d'une municipalité gaspée avez-vous ce
genre de situation là vous vous des gens
qui vous disent je voudrais quitter vous
essayez de les garder comment ça se
passe à Gasper
en fait chez nous ça se passe très bien
j'ai personne qui a voulu quitter on
aurait eu aucune démission se fait un
peu plus de 9 ans que je suis mère et
c'est dans la ville de Gaspé et aucune
démission aucune amorce de démission en
9 ans il y a eu des élections il y a eu
des changements après élection mais en
cours de mandat j'ai un conseiller qui
est décédé en cours de mandat mais j'ai
personne qui a démissionne et je sais
aussi que dans certaines municipalités
c'est le climat de travail au sein même
entre des conseillers qui n'ont pas
nécessairement les mêmes allégeances
effectivement ça arrive aussi ça arrive
aussi mais en fait ce qu'on fait comme
rappel c'est on est tous on est tous
dans le même bateau on travaille tous
pour les mêmes objectifs
ultimement peut-être pas de la même
manière de le faire peut-être qu'on a
pas exactement les mêmes priorités moi
j'invite toujours les gens à travailler
ce qui fait le plus consensus que
possible attention les titres rivalités
personnelles oui on fait de la politique
des fois ça peut provoquer certaines
rivalités ça peut provoquer certaines
tensions c'est normal mais on est tous
humains derrière tout ça ça sert à rien
d'attaquer l'humain derrière tout ça
faisons des débats d'idées et c'est ce
que lui aime plus propose aussi dans le
cas de ces campagnes de sensibilisation
oui au début autant entre élus qu'avec
les citoyens mais attention les attaques
personnelles on est en 2023 on n'est pas
là non plus pour ce
démolir humainement alors on est tous
des humains on a tous des familles on a
tous des valeurs on a tous des vies en
dehors de la vie politique faisons
attention à ça tout va bien aller ouais
parce que je voyais notamment le maire
c'est de Trois Rivières si je ne m'abuse
il y a quelques semaines à peine il a
dit moi on va prendre une pause j'en ai
besoin si on comprend bien pour sa santé
mentale et il l'évêque avait quitté dans
des circonstances bon de maladies mais
il avait dit aussi écouté c'était
terrible le climat de travail c'est bien
dommage des solutions pour endiguer ce
départ vous semblez en avoir chez vous
en tout cas
en fait des solutions partout ce que de
l'humain il y aura de l'humainerie donc
d'abord et avant tout je pense qu'elle
passe par de la sensibilisation d'une
part pour éviter des démissions par
rapport aux gens qui peuvent qui
n'avaient pas anticipé le flux de
travail on doit les sensibiliser
qu'est-ce que les attend avant d'être
élu municipal premièrement deuxièmement
sur le climat on doit continuer de
sensibiliser aussi sur le fait que
derrière les politiciens on est tous des
humains donc faut faire attention c'est
à ce type de relation là faire des
débats d'idées etc par ailleurs on doit
aussi promouvoir la fonction de l'une
municipales le MQ le fait avec
différents prix qui reconnaissent les
meilleurs coûts qui reconnaissent les
meilleurs en fait
c'est lu que ce sont des marqués au
cours des années juste par ces étapes
dans le dos là on donne de bons exemples
positifs aussi sur comment on devrait
agir et comment on devrait mener une vie
municipale bref il y a toujours de
manière à y arriver mais je pense que
vous sensibilisation de me remonter bien
expliqué qu'elle est la tâche et ses
limites aussi je l'ai bien compris dans
l'entrevue merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Maire merci merci à vous à la prochaine
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI